Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. If you have not
heard about Truther Con, I'm about to
show you that trailer right now because
you guys don't want to miss Truther Con
2025. Check this out.
Of course.
Well, well, technical difficulties
during the live, guys. But uh here, let
me let me pull it up. Let me let me
introduce the crew real quick. I got my
friends.
>> Oh my god.
>> Jeremiah and Jake in here. What's up,
guys?
>> What's up, man?
>> I didn't know you spoke fluent.
>> Whatever that was.
>> I don't know how you did that, but that
was amazing.
>> I know.
>> Good to be here.
>> Thanks, man. Yeah, that's been happening
lately. I don't know why I download a
video. And I guess if there's if there's
like a dubbed thing, it only downloads
that version. But um yeah, let me let me
show the uh website and
the the trailer. If you guys in the chat
have not heard about Truther Con, it's
coming October 25th through 26. There's
going to be a bunch of guest speakers.
Get your tickets today. Uh News Nation
is the ones putting this out and those
are my brothers in here right now. And
there's going to be performances by
Bryson Gray. There's going to be all
these speakers, man. This is going to be
amazing actually. Wow. Josh Keefe from
Flat Earth Brothers. Founded Earth
Brothers. K. Podi. Is that how you say
your last name?
>> Pi I think.
>> Pi. She's like new upcoming like going
viral with the truth right now, man.
It's so cool you guys got her. Dave
Weiss and uh I can't wait to meet some
of these other guys as well.
>> It's funny. She's like the number one
person that all the other speakers are
like, "Oh my gosh, she's going to be
there."
>> Yeah.
>> I was like, "Yeah, I mean, she said
right here." So,
>> she's a rising star in the truther
community. Um, let me see if I can pull
up the
See if I can pull up your
uh
>> I know my grandpa just laughed too when
it was in German because he is German.
>> Oh, that's awesome.
>> He's He's our producer, too, Opa. He's
awesome,
>> dude. You must have a cool grandpa.
>> Yeah, he's the coolest.
>> Wait, is it on where where is that
trailer? Is it on Skiba Nation News?
>> Go to uh videos, I guess.
H. Usually it's like right there on the
homepage.
>> Yeah, that's kind of strange. Uh, if you
go down a little bit, it was not too
long ago that I posted that one.
>> Really? So, under videos
>> playlist.
>> Is this it? Promo
>> 58 seconds.
>> Uh, that's for that's for an episode.
Keep going down. Okay. See the neon uh
this?
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
All right, let me turn it up.
This
>> something huge is coming. We're building
the world's largest truther convention.
It's called Truther Con.
>> This is the place where truthers unite
to explore knowledge, ask tough
questions to challenge the mainstream
narrative.
>> But it isn't just a convention. It's a
movement for free thought, open
discussion, and the right to question
everything.
>> We are bringing in some of the biggest
names of the truther community. So,
expect deep discussions, mindblowing
revelations, and connections with
like-minded truth seekers.
>> If you feel like the truth is being
hidden from you, this is where you need
to be.
>> And the best part, it's 100% grassroots,
built by truthers for truthers, straight
from our News Nation family. Truther Con
will be a massive networking event. I
believe this is going to be the most
exciting truther event ever.
>> October 2025 in Dallas, Texas. We hope
to see you there.
[Music]
Boom. That got me excited. Dallas,
Texas. I've only gotten to go to Texas
two or three times. I love it from
Haven't really gotten to like tour
around or anything, but they got some
really cool conventions that I've been
to. So, looking forward to it. And and
if you think about it, that's the first
time that's the first place, first event
happened where they called us conspiracy
theorists. People who disagree with the
official narrative conspiracy theorist.
And that was in the Warren Commission
report,
>> which is famously known the JFK
assassination.
>> We all know Lee Harvey Oswwell was
innocent. Let's be honest.
>> But I that's what I'm speaking about is
is where the fatal shot came from. And I
have
>> like like props and stuff like I want to
present it as like I'm a prosecutor
trying to convince you that what I'm
saying is true and you can either
believe me or not believe it or not.
>> I can't wait to see that cuz I I kind of
woke up to conspiracy theories from well
I'll say I at some point
around senior year of high school which
was a long time ago. I'm 41 or
something. But uh was the moon landing,
but I I didn't see the big picture.
That's the thing. Like I would see
things like, okay, that was like a fake
event or something, but it was like I
didn't see that it played into this big
new world order thing. So I remember
believing, yep, that that was faked and
everybody bought into that. And then in
208, no, 2008, my dad actually showed me
loose change. He was like, "Dude," and I
I thought at that time I thought consp
conspiracy theorists were crazy. I was
like I was just living in the world just
doing whatever, you know, just in a
drunken haze partying. And uh didn't
think that there was any kind of grand
conspiracy or anything. And he said,
"Man, I know I know you don't believe in
this stuff most of the time, but just
watch Loose Change with me." And I
watched it and I was like, whoa, this
was 100% inside job. But I, again, I
still couldn't see the big picture. That
was 2008. I was like, okay, there was
this corrupt event. It was, you know,
probably for oil or money or hiding, you
know, something that they didn't want
people to see. Whatever it was, I knew
it had to do with like greed and
corruption. But I didn't see it past
that until December 2011. December 2011
was when like God knocked the blinders
off my eyes and I could just see
everything like whoa. Like all the
corporate logos, the hospital logo, like
subliminal messages and TV, all that
stuff. And from 2011, I've just never
been able to see the world the same
since.
>> And that's what you're going to be
speaking about at TruthCon, which is
going to be pretty awesome, I think.
>> Yeah. I actually I got a lot of
different presentations I can talk
about. I didn't know which one you you
guys picked for me to talk about, but
Hollywood, aliens, whatever. But mainly
that's what it is. Like mind control.
Like there's there's a puppet master
that's pulling the strings of Hollywood,
the music industry, politics, all of it.
And the news.
>> Yeah, it it's crazy, man. Even with this
recent event that happened with Charlie
Kirk, I mean, it's like the you can you
can almost parallel look at that and
then look at JFK and how they were both
assassinated and why they were
assassinated because they were big
voices.
>> Wow.
>> And they were trying to do things that
the that the, you know, mainstream and
the
>> them whoever them is,
>> uh, you know, didn't like them. So,
>> yeah, dude. That's why it's hard to
know, man. Like cuz I'm at a place now
where I'm like anyone 100% of anybody in
politics or has a big platform on the
mainstream media news, it's all
propaganda. They're all in they're all
like in the club or whatever. And I
don't know when that actually started
because I actually believe JFK was
really trying to to wake people up. I
mean, he his last speech was talking
about exposing the Freemasons and the
very word secrecy in a
>> Oh, yeah. open and free society is
repugnant and all this stuff and boom
they got him.
>> Yeah. So, did you know that the Zapruder
film the famous footage that you see uh
on everything? I mean, it's it's
everywhere. That's the number one
footage is the back and to the left
footage, right?
>> That didn't premiere until the Haraldo
Rivera show in the 70s.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Isn't that crazy to think about? So,
>> yeah.
>> For the longest time, all these people
like uh this book is I have right here.
I'm going to use it in my presentation,
but some of the drawings in this book
are identical to the Zapruder film,
which is insane. The fact that they were
able to in their mind know exactly what
happened.
>> Yeah, man. I'm interested to see what
you got on that because I've heard so
many different things. I've heard, well,
for one, with the Mandela effect, like
how many how many rows of seats were
there? That's crazy. And then
like I've heard that um this driver
might have turned like turned around and
shot him.
>> I don't know what you think about some
of I don't even know where you're coming
from. So I'm really interested.
>> Well, being from Dallas, I did a whole
seventh grade presentation on that uh
about the driver's thing.
>> And uh the thing is if you look at the
guy next to the driver, if you look at
his head, there's a glare on his head.
And it does look like a gun.
if I could say that. I don't know if we
can say pew pew. It looks like a pew pew
or whatever,
>> man. I don't censor anything.
>> I know. I just
>> Yeah.
All right. But yeah, that that's what I
personally think. But, you know, with
AI, you can't really tell anything
anymore. But we do know that the
Zapruder film as of right now
>> is is a real piece of footage. So
>> yeah, the zaprruder film in this
situation would be the cameras that they
removed during the active crime scene
and they went up there and they stood on
the chair he was literally just shot in
and they take down these cameras that
had the direct close-up view and all
these cameras, you know, were taken
away.
>> Um, so could that footage be what the
supruder footage is in the next 15 years
from now? They're going to release this
close-up shot or whatever. And and
honestly, we a lot of us watched it
together and it's a a group trauma we've
all experienced. And whenever you see
things like this that deeply and
emotionally impact people all over uh
who've watched it, um it's triggering
us. And the subconscious trauma that we
all feel, uh what it does is it causes a
stressor that allows you to be pushed
one way or another. And that's how these
trauma events, these SCOPs and and even
real trauma that is just grabbed hold of
and they make the the best out of a bad
situation, you know, so to speak.
>> Yeah.
>> And so that's really what you know what
we see with this thing is uh you have
this situation where um you have another
divide situation happening all across
the country which is really interesting
to just to watch
>> across the world. Dude, this is crazy.
Like I can't believe I see footage from
people in China, UK. Like, dude, I I I
showed a video last night. I just went
live talking about this thing for two
hours and there's a video clip showing
people all all over the world. And I
thought, well, maybe they're just maybe
it's some other kind of rally, but
they're actually showing people holding
signs of Charlie and saying Charlie,
Charlie, and all that stuff. I'm like,
how did this become a worldwide thing?
>> Yeah, it's intense.
But Jake, you're going to have to remind
me of what you said about how the
parallels go together. Maybe you'll just
have to get help me do the presentation.
>> You'll be my uh co co-prosecutor.
>> So, I don't know what angle you guys are
looking at with what just happened, but
I did a video on it last night. Like I
said, I I automatically when I see
politics, mainstream media, news
coverage like that, and somebody that
has a huge platform like that, like
rubbing shoulders with the president,
Trump, and all that, I I know I don't
know. I'm I'm assuming you guys are on
the same page that both right, left and
right, are both the two wings of the
same feather or two wings of the same
bird. There's there's a puppet master
controlling both sides. And really, I
don't think your vote counts. I think
it's all planned. I think
what they do is it's it's divide and
conquer. It's order out of chaos. It's
we're going to we're going to roll this
new world order agenda out steps at a
time and two steps forward, one step
back. So, we're going to do a lot of
stuff to tick you off, but then we're
next next term, you're gonna get to get
your guy because, you know, after four
years, the left is mad. They want their
side. So now we're going to give you
your guy and we're going to take back
some of that stuff, but we're going to,
you know, two steps forward, one step
back. We're going to take back some of
it to appease you, but the agenda is
still rolling out. So over the years,
it's been going on like a frog in the
kettle to where each generation is just
desensitized to what laws are coming out
and what freedoms are being taken away
until ultimately new world order will
come about. And uh it doesn't matter
which side is in. And so, yeah, when I
see somebody in those types of platforms
and politics, I'm I'm already like
skeptical, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> Like skeptical like it hit him or
>> skeptical? Like I think those people are
like there's there's people and I don't
know, maybe you're one of them, but
there's people that really think Trump
is like he's going to stop New World
Order, like he's not a part of the club
and stuff. I thought you were gonna say
Elvis because I I battles with you.
>> I'm a I'm a huge Elvis fan and I can
tell you everything you need to know
about Elvis and Trump is not Elvis.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I want to say oh about Elvis.
>> No. Like where do you guys stand on what
do you think's going on with the
political world and
>> Oh
yes. So, um I learned in a in an
interview we did with um Tom O'Neal uh
that whenever it comes to these MK Ultra
SCPY type events,
>> what they do is they use a uh
>> kind of it's like they use a judicial
process to set a precedence for whatever
agenda that they want to roll out and
they get us all emotionally charged to
support the process so that they can put
it into legislation that they can then
enforce. at point of gun. And so what is
the SCOP in this situation? Well, we got
to look at several things. Uh what
happened the exact day of the shooting
and things that have been rolled out
since then in relation to it. And so
what we saw is that for one, Congress
voted on the Epstein files, the day
Charlie was shot,
>> that got disappeared, right? That whole
concept of the Epstein files is now
going to be
>> forgotten, so to speak. I mean, I'm sure
there's going to be trumpets here and
there, but
>> the timing impeccable, right? Here's the
other aspect. You have the trans shooter
connection, right? How is it bad for us
to be worried about mentally ill people
being restricted from guns, right? Oh,
is it a big deal that uh you know, these
people that are identifying as trans
individuals are shooting others and
they're becoming this target for
legislation to restrict people like
that? Well, how will that directly
affect you and me? Well, think about
this. Who defines the mental health that
restricts somebody's access to weapons?
If the ideology of trans people is
showing that they're crazy because
they're like, "Okay, I'm a boy when
you're actually a girl or I'm a girl
when you're actually a boy."
>> Well, guess what's very similar to that?
>> I believe in God, an imaginary person.
>> I'm a bornag again believer.
>> Yeah.
>> How can you be born again? You're not
born again. You're you're crazy
>> and you're not allowed to have a gun
anymore. So this is the kind of
precedences that are set in these
situations and and this is how they get
us is they get us all emotionally
charged and supportive of whatever
solution comes in. And you know you got
you know the Hegelian dialectic
terminology. Everybody on your audience
probably does. But
>> y
>> yeah I'm glad you guys are on the same
page because that's exactly what I think
you you nailed it man. Like even already
so quickly after this event happened,
people are losing their jobs for social
media posts, if you say something that's
remotely insensitive, like, "Oh, we
don't care that he got shot or whatever,
you get fired." I mean, that's taken
away freedom of speech right there. And
and actually, the left has some really
good points right now. We were watching
some videos last night of of you know
left leftist type people talking
liberals talking to the camera saying um
this is a really hypocritical double
standard how when George Floyd thing was
going on you guys didn't care you mocked
us when you know you were making fun of
the whole al alligator Alcatraz and
taking pictures and all this stuff and
mocking and all this stuff but now if we
simply say you know I don't care that
he's gone I lose my job, but nothing
happened on this side. So, they're
purposely I believe the the elites are
purposely dividing us on every angle.
Gender division, religion division,
political division. And dude, they they
got us right where they want us. And and
the term
civil war is surging right now because
right now the right are calling for like
we need to fight back. Even did you see
Elon Musk talking to those UK people?
>> So
>> yeah,
>> you saw that. So he's wearing the the
all-seeing eye on his shirt. He's
talking live stream to people a big
rally in the UK and he's saying um you
need to fight back or die. And like
everybody cheers and he goes, "Yeah."
And he's just like hyping them up like
fight back. This is the richest man on
earth telling mobs of people fight. I
mean, this is like, you know, a super
villain in a movie like Hunger Games.
Like the richest man telling the
peasants, "Fight, fight, fight." You
know, it's like, dude, this is crazy.
And I I think that uh it's order out of
chaos. They have to create the chaos to
bring in the new world order. And people
are going to be happy with it because
it's going to be so much better than the
chaos that we just got out of. So, just
like 9/11, like, "Yes, please frisk me
at every uh every airport and tap all my
phones. I don't care. I don't I'm not
doing anything wrong." That's our
mindset. Like, I'm not a terrorist. So,
I don't care if they listen to every
conversation I have. Well, what if the
law says uh if you're a Christian,
you're a terrorist, or if you're a
homeschooler, if you're antivax or
whatever. What if those things become,
you know, put you on the list? Now, you
do care that they're listening to
everything you say.
It's a good point.
>> It's the bullhip effect. It's It's how
we can all support something that sounds
good, but we jump into our own boiling
water because the same infrastructure
that we're setting up for now, right
now, considering DOG and AI
infrastructure, it might be great under
the control of a conservative president,
conservative administration, whatever.
Hey, he's exposing corruption. He's
using AI to do good, do good, do good.
And then you've already stepped fully
into the trap. Clamps shut. Next
administration rolls in. All of the
infrastructurees put in place and they
just flip the switch to red, you know,
flipped it to blue or, you know,
whatever. And and we've sold our souls
because of the good it's doing. And and
it's just like, man,
>> wow, man.
>> So, I want to hype people up for this. I
don't I actually haven't had time to
promote yet. What is So, we got a just a
little longer than a month for
this event. Oh, no, that's the wrong
button.
For this event that's going to have all
these guest speakers talking about
awesome things in Dallas, Texas, October
25th, October 26. So, mark your
calendars. You can go on here and buy
the tickets right off of here. you can
actually become you can apply to be a
vendor which is awesome and it's a great
opportunity to meet like-minded people
to network and that's what I'm excited
about. I'm excited to get to meet people
that I've, you know, talked to a little
bit online and and just I've been to a
couple different events and it's always
just such a breath of fresh air to be
around people that actually understand
the world the way we do.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You know, me and you, Mikey,
we ran into each other the first time at
FEIC
2019.
>> My booth.
>> That was Dallas
>> was just down the hallway. Yeah. Down in
Dallas. And that's actually the first
>> Yeah, man. We We were doing our uh What
if the Earth is flat documentary had
come out that year and uh I was
promoting that for Now You See TV at the
time, who I had worked for for a few
years. But man, Dallas is such an
interesting place because you have so
many people who are moving to Texas, uh,
like the Exodus from California and all
that kind of stuff. And and there's so
many of these figures that are plopping
down in places like Austin and Dallas
that are like these big culture
influencers. And so it's it's kind of
like we're bringing the the the battle
to, you know, to present to the world,
right? bring your finest, you know, all
the truthers, all the questions you
might have and, you know, come and hang
out. You know, I think the value in a
conference like this is one, you know,
something we haven't had for many years
since some of those big flat earth
conferences and some of the other ones
that were take on the world was one that
we went to regularly.
>> But, uh, the concept is this. Whenever
you only have so much time in the world
and there's a water hose of agendas and
things being shot at you, there's only
so much time in the world to watch
videos and to do research, to read a
book, to to to get some understanding,
right? Understanding is very important
in these days we live in now. When you
come to truth or con, our whole premise
of this is that we take speakers who are
experts in their fields of research that
have very pressing and important truths
for now for today and they take the the
most important most condensed
nitty-gritty truths that they have to
share and uh and then we put it all
together so that we save time for
people. And not only that, you start to
get the interactions with these
wellrespected, very uh wellressearched,
intelligent people. And it's their
crossexaminations and back and forth
that is going to be really exciting to
see because you're going to have things
that are discussed that normally, you
know, every once in a while you get a
good question right from the audience.
>> Yeah. But when you have two really
bright minds like some researchers like
Gary Wayne or whoever uh with these
depths of knowledge that they can draw
on man some of the things that are going
to be brought to light and the notes
that are going to be cross-co compared
I'm just so excited for that just man
it's going to be it's going to be really
cool and so that's just a kind of a sum
up of what we have in mind after every
session we're going to have audience
able to ask questions
>> um and then of course we we don't want
to end in a sober, somber, you know,
depressing note. And so, guess what?
>> Bryson Gray wrapping up the whole
conference, whole con, you know, it's
going to be a blast.
>> So, that's going to be like the
headlining closing thing.
>> Yeah. What What a better way to end, you
know?
>> Yeah, man.
>> That's a good idea,
>> man. I can't keep up with uh all the
things that are being said in the chat,
but I do see one. It's a a Hebrew name.
I can't pronounce, but it says uh the
world is demonstrabably a sphere though.
I I haven't seen that evidence.
Um
>> I I saw somebody say that I was on
anti-depressants, which is kind of
funny.
>> I don't
>> Do you agree that happy or something?
>> My only anti-depressant
because I lost both my parents. But
>> you know, you got to stay busy. I would
say that that's
>> that's what drives me doing truth or con
doing Ski News Nation.
>> Amen. that you gotta stay busy, man.
>> Yeah, man.
>> By the way,
>> not Elvis, but
>> that's what's up.
>> Yeah, man. I uh I had a special needs
daughter that was 15 that passed
four years ago. I can't believe it's
been that long. And then my mom just
passed in March. So, I feel you, man.
And and it is like God keeps you busy.
And there's nothing more fulfilling.
I've done all the stuff of the world,
man. My my testimony is I I was like an
upcoming rapper. I was basically locally
famous getting a Bud Ice sponsorship for
concerts and rubbing shoulders with
Soulja Boy and models all around the
world wearing my clothing line and all
this stuff. And I was about to move to
California
and it was like God drew a line in the
sand and said, "You can have this dream
that you want. If you pursue it, it's
going to happen. and you see the
sponsorships and the, you know, all the
connections and everything's working out
or you can lay it all down and follow
what I have for you. And I chose in that
moment, God, I want whatever you have
for me because I know you're real. I
know you're I I trust you and I believe
in you and I trust your plan for my
life. And it was kind of a scary thing
because I thought, man, God's going to
take away all my dreams. like I I love
making t-shirts and graphics and videos
and uh traveling the world and being on
stage and stuff like that. Well, guess
what? God gave me those gifts. I was
using them the wrong way. I was using
them for the world. And now that God's
put me in ministry, I still make
t-shirts. I still make graphics and
videos. I still get to travel the world
and be on stage. But now it's all to
glorify him instead of myself. And you
know that lifestyle,
I'm not going to lie, it was fun, but it
was fun for a night and then it was the
next day regret. You know, I'd wake up
the next day and be like, "Oh, what
happened?" And people are telling me two
hours of things I have no recollection
of and things that I would never do in
my sober mind because those spirits that
you drink were taking over and the the
marijuana and everything else. And it
was like
I never regret going somewhere and
speaking about my testimony or what
God's shown me and sharing truth. Never
once have I went somewhere and said,
"Man, I wish I wouldn't have done that."
Like that was that was so embarrassing
or so regretful. No, it's God's purpose
is eternal purpose and there's eternal
value in that stuff. And it's it's the
it's the most fulfilling thing I've ever
done in my life, sharing truth.
>> Yeah. That's awesome.
>> Hey, I wanted to address the uh the the
comment. Uh, you know, whenever you're
like the Earth was provably a sphere,
whenever you think about people that
have actually witnessed it with their
very own eyes,
no one other than those who claim to
have gone to the ISS or to beyond low
Earth orbit uh space missions like in
the 70s and 80s can say verifiably that
they've seen anything about a curve with
their own eyes. So, we have to trust
>> all of these individuals. And I believe
it's only close to 600 people that have
ever been beyond low Earth orbit high
enough with the curvature is actually
even visible. Most people look out of an
airplane flying all over the Earth and
they see, oh, I kind of see a curve
there. But what you're seeing is the the
glass of the airplane
>> demonstrabably curving your view. uh
because at that altitude 30,000 feet you
can't see any curvature at all. The
horizon rises to eye level and not only
that uh Neil deGrasse Tyson
>> says that you can't even see the
curvature at over
127,000
ft.
>> Now do you know how high that is? Just
recently we had Felix Bombgardner passed
away and uh always
>> yeah a question to me about like what
happened there but he suddenly passed
away but he was the Red Bull jumper who
jumped from 127,000 ft and the footage
that they put out was so uh
obviously skewed with fisheye lens uh
that when he he gets down to the earth
the earth looks like a ball as he's
landing.
And Neil deGrasse Tyson came out and
said and and he's this head scientist of
scientism. You know,
>> he's anti Earth all the way.
>> Yeah, for sure. He says that even at
127,000 ft, Felix Bombgardner would have
seen a completely flat horizon. So,
>> let's just put it out this way.
Regardless of how you feel about it, you
have to admit that you always have to
trust the word or images from people
that have been verified liars in the
past, right? You have to trust these
people if the earth is a sphere or not.
Because truly, unless you see it with
your own eyes, will you ever know? Will
you for sure ever know? Because our
experience here walking this earth is
flat, stationary. You don't feel the
earth moving. You don't feel the shift
of speed as the earth slows down its
orbit around the you know all of these
variables that we've been told just are
unmeasurable
and so that I think that is a you know
what I wanted to address because look
>> you know science truth is not beyond
reproach everything should be able to be
questioned and so even people that
present the earth is flat
>> you know definitely uh at the conference
we're going to have people that don't
believe the earth is flat and we're
going to give you the opportunity to
hard question anybody that's presenting
any aspect of cosmology or whatever
because we're not trying to push an
ideology that's just as cultish as
modern scientism and and evolution and
all these things where it's like I'm in
a white lab coat trust what I say accept
it as as word of God basically and and
it's you're unfortunately we live in a
culture that's very expert oriented in
our opinions you see it even in
congressional hearings where somebody
will go up there and they'll say, "Well,
I'm not a biologist, but uh I you know,
you guess you could call me a boy,
right?" And it's or whatever the the
various, you know, things are. But
>> yeah, actually there's another good
question, but I want to pull up that
because I thought of this clip right
before you mentioned it. And here's Neil
Degrass Tyson what he said about the
edge of space jump.
>> And that dude who jumped out of a
perfectly good balloon. Um what's his
Felix? Felix Bumgardner. Uh he would
have been about 2 millimeters above the
surface of this globe. That's his edge
of space jump.
Now, you know, I don't it's he wants to
I don't have a problem if he does it,
but the the honesty of it would greatly
diminish what I think people thought he
was actually doing. And not only that,
they made sure to photograph him
standing there with a really wide angle
lens which curves horizontal lines.
>> So, in the photo, you see this curvature
of Earth's surface and he's, "Wow, he's
in space. Look at that." No, he's not.
At that height, you don't see you don't
see the curvature of the earth if you
are 2 mm above this beach ball.
You just don't.
That stuff is flat.
>> Oh, I love that.
>> That stuff is flat. That stuff is flat.
>> Uh he told us, man. So, yeah, no matter
how high up you go, even in a balloon,
we don't see curvature. I mean, these
high altitude balloons are going way
higher than any commercial flight that
any of us have ever taken. And
if it's not using a GoPro lens, it's
just a flat horizontal line all the way
around.
And if that's the case, if no matter how
high up you are, you can't see
curvature. You know, we're told that you
can sit on the shore of a beach and
watch ships sail right over the curve.
Now, if that's true, if you can actually
watch a ship go so far out that it goes
over the curve, yet at this height,
you don't see curvature. He said that
stuff is flat. That means the Earth is
shaped like a cylinder, like a Coke can
because ships can go over this way, but
they but you can't even detect it side
to side. So that tells us you have to
put all the pieces together. You have to
look at all the evidence and say, "Well,
what's going on here? How come how come
it seems like I can watch a ship go over
the edge, but I can't see it
horizontal?" And you have to look deeper
and say, "Well, is there another reason
that could make ships appear to be going
over the edge?"
>> Well, I will say my dad made this really
cool thing called a refraction kit, and
somebody just bought like 20 of them,
and and it was like some of the last
ones my mom ever made, too, and my wife
made some of them. But, uh, the I was I
remember the first time he came home and
he was like, "Hey, so the Earth is
flat." I was like, "You're you're crazy,
dude. like don't don't even like I was
laughing at him and I I I feel bad now
that I laughed but then he proved me
wrong and I
>> we were all there man
>> I know but
>> 100% of flatearthers were not flat
earthers at one point in time
>> right but this is your dad telling you
that you know what I mean and then my
mom telling me that and then everybody
telling me that and I'm like okay I
guess there's something to it and then
researching it and it's crazy journey
Ernie.
>> So, what is that kit?
>> The refraction kit.
>> Yeah. What does that do exactly?
>> It what it does is it has I don't have
one by me. Uh there's like a little ship
like a like and it shows you like where
the horizon is. Jake, you might be able
to end this video.
>> Oh, really?
>> Uh yeah, this video I think shows his uh
one of his early prototypes or one of
these. Yeah, maybe scroll to the end.
What I thought was interesting about
this, when I first saw it, I wasn't
quite getting it. And so if anybody's
watching this like, what is this
supposed to prove?
>> If you take Earth and it's a ball and
you rise off of it, at some point
because the horiz the horizon is going
curving outward away from you, at some
point in a plane or balloon or whatever,
you're going to have to start looking
down. That horizon's going to go down,
down, down till you're starting to look
down at a ball. But that's not what we
see. The higher you go up, you keep
look. It's still I I I kept hearing
people say the the horizon is flat and
rises to eye level. And I was like,
rises to eye level? What does that mean?
It means you can stare out the window no
matter how high you are. It's always
going to be right in front of you. It's
always going to be flat, meaning that
it's not curving downward to the point
where you have to look down to see it.
And so this this is a CGI demonstration
of what that how that would look. Um,
one thing I thought was awesome
was the sun how sunsets work and I use
that so many times because so many
people That's a question.
>> I pulled it up here.
>> You have it?
>> I pulled it up on share screen here.
>> Oh, wait. How do I do that? Oh.
Huh. Uh, I don't know how to show that.
That would be awesome if I could. Let me
see.
I don't have the option to make this
show that.
What's the Is it on this YouTube?
>> Yeah, it's it's just type Robkea
refraction and it's like the top one of
the top videos. It's like a two-minute
>> atmospheric refraction.
>> Yeah, there you go.
>> Oh, you see that? Yep.
>> Yep. There it is. That's really
prototype.
>> Uh using the sheet right here set.
>> So this is how the sunset is explained
for those who are curious.
>> This is how the sunset can work without
the you know why does the sun set,
right? How could that make sense if it's
just going further away? Well, this is
how it's made sense. And to show what's
going on in this little screen right
here, basically, you can see too far.
That's like a huge evidence that we
don't live on a spinning ball is there
was a photographer that took a picture
of the city of Lake or the city of
Chicago from the other side of Lake
Michigan. Right? Am I getting that
right? So, he's standing on the shore of
Lake Michigan taking a picture of the
whole cityscape of Chicago. And I've
I've done the math. I mean, you can look
up what's the tallest skyscraper or
what's the tallest building in Chicago.
It'll tell you. And then you look at how
far it is from that shore to the city
and you go to earth curvature calculator
and you put in the mileage and you put
in how tall the person was. You can you
can exaggerate. You can say he was 10 ft
tall. And the tallest building in
Chicago should be covered by like a I
don't want to exaggerate, but feet of
curvature. I I think it's like 100 feet
of curvature, but even the tallest
building would not be visible. And yet
he was able to see the whole city
skyline. And a newscaster said, "Oh,
what you're seeing is a mirage." And so
he's saying, you know, using all this
stuff, he's saying that the atmosphere
is like uh is like a magnifying glass.
So there's moisture in the atmosphere
and it causes atmospheric magnification
and all this stuff and it's actually
pulling the image up. So Robkea,
Jeremiah's dad,
put this together by with a This is
what's awesome about science is you can
test it. It's testable. It's observable.
It's repeatable. And um this is what
really happens when you put that to the
test. So in this bottom here, the guy is
talking about, you know, that's why
you're able to see this mirage is
because of
Yeah. lensing effect.
But just like a pencil and a glass of
water, it makes the pencil look larger
and it pulls the image downward. not
doesn't pull the image upward and it
makes the image look larger.
>> That's That's kind of like the one
that's in our shop. It's It's pretty
cool.
>> Yeah, I'd love to get one of those.
Let's see what he's saying here.
>> Magnifying sheet and pasted the city on
the back there. And I made it as two
separate pieces so that I could uh flex
it as necessary because I think that
there are different types of atmospheric
conditions that would allow for more
magnification versus less magnification.
So in this scenario, you have more
magnification. And in this one, you have
less. And for this one, I decided to put
the Toronto skyline into my little box
here. And let's try it again. Okay,
we're all the way up against the glass.
Now, let's zoom across the lake.
>> And wow, look at that. More portions
start to disappear. Now, let's zoom back
in
>> on a flat surface.
>> Get a little closer to the one that uh
Captain Ballard was talking about here.
>> And wow, look at this. Here's his image
on the right. And here's my image on the
left.
>> Missing lower portion of the city. Had
nothing to do with curvature whatsoever.
>> Yeah. So, what was awesome was Rob
actually put it to the test. He got in a
boat and zoomed in on that city skyline
and just traveled the whole lake,
keeping it in the shot, proving that it
wasn't some mirage. Miragages are always
distorted. They're, you know, floating.
That's why you have these ghost ship
type anomalies where ships look like
they're floating or even inverted images
like I guess like projector screens
where the image is actually upside down.
So there was no distortion on the city,
no upside down, no floating.
And then Rob proved it by just keeping
it in the camera the whole time.
And so somebody said, um, if the Earth
is flat, then the moon is flat, too. But
that's like saying that because the pool
table's flat, all the balls are flat as
well. We can't judge what we're standing
on by looking up in the sky. I mean, the
Bible talks about that
he created there was nothing and then he
created a firmament which was a a
glass-like dome structure that that
separated the waters below from the
waters above. So, if we're going to go
by what the Bible alone says, and this
is creation week, this isn't, you know,
some prophetic symbolic vision or
metaphor or poetry or anything.
What What is that? What is this dome,
glass dome- like structure that's firm,
a firmament that's dividing the waters
below from the waters above? What is up
there? It's not an everexpanding vacuum.
It's water. And it says that the sun,
moon, and stars are in the firmament. So
if if we want to, you know, say, oh,
well, the firmament that that was just
them talking about the atmosphere or
clouds. I've heard people say that the
the waters above is clouds, then we have
a huge problem because it says that the
sun, moon, and stars, which are supposed
to be the furthest things that we can
see, are in the firmament, in our
atmosphere, in our clouds.
So, I actually do believe what the Bible
says that there is a a strong structure
above us that contains it's like a
clock. The the sun and the moon are
relatively the same size, the same
distance. They're local. They're
traveling around this flat plane like
like a clock that's regulating
temperature day and night. All those
things.
You were going to say something, Jake?
>> Oh, yeah. Um, I I just uh I see comments
like talking about the the final
experiment stuff with the 24-hour sun
and and uh I I want people to understand
that there are other explanations uh
that have come out. Uh Joseph Hanvy, I
believe, is a really fascinating
experiment. um through his models that
he's created, he's shown that a single
light source can be refracted into a uh
a pseudo 24-hour sun. Um so I would I
would highly encourage people if they're
interested in like something that might
explain the 24-hour sun in um Antarctica
uh after the FIC the I mean the uh the
final experiment thing. Joe Hanvy.
Really interesting uh research.
>> But um I I unfortunately guys I have to
jump off. My wife is calling me. I need
to go and help her here for a moment.
But I did want to say just to wrap up
that I wanted to extend a branch to
Christians that might not be
flat-earthers still because obviously
that you know we're going to have people
that are of various persuasions. And for
example, we just interviewed uh Dr. for
Kent Hovind who is a
>> very not flat earthminded individual.
>> But I think the common interest and love
for the truth and the love for scripture
can bring people together. And believe
it or not, if you think the earth isn't
flat, you still have more in common with
flatearthers than you do the traditional
scientism, evolutionary spinny monkey
ball religion that has indoctrinated us
all since youth. And and it's funny
because while some people might be like,
"Oh, flat Earth is too stigmatizing.
This is too weird."
>> People will very easily start to
question things like, "Oh,
helioentrism." Wait, there's evidence
that the red shift could prove some case
for geocentrism. And that totally
unravels this theory of uh galactic big
bang evolution and all this kind of
stuff that's been tethered to this house
of cards of theories. And people have to
recognize that theories are not fact.
And theories like the theory of gravity,
the theory of this or that, they have
evidences, things we witness, observe.
But
>> when it comes to flat earth, there are
many evidences that operate in much like
an inverse equation. What that means is
if the sun is very large and very far
away, it will cause the same effect as
the other side of the equation which is
inverted which is the sun could still
cause the same observable phenomenon if
it's much smaller and much closer.
>> And so you don't have to just come up
with these fantastical perspectives of
how reality works. you can still be very
science-based and and empirically minded
as a questioning cosmologist.
So, for people that are listening and
are like, "Whoa, you know, these people
are totally off the rocker.
>> Come on, show up to Truth or Con. You're
going to have a lot of questions. Uh,
and I think people will have a lot of
answers." But
>> anyways, guys, you you guys feel free to
carry on shortly if you want. Um, I'm
sorry I had to jump off a little bit
early here. Oh,
>> you're good.
>> But, uh, really enjoyed our
conversation, Mikey. Thanks for having
having us on.
>> Yeah, thanks Jake. I look forward to
being at the Truther Con and I hope to
see everybody there. Did you want to
keep going, Jeremiah? Are you
>> I got I got about five minutes. I should
probably go, too. My wife is making
dinner, but uh
>> Hey, I I
>> I appreciate all you guys in the in the
chat and just being here. It's It's so
cool to uh to just meet you in Well,
it's going to be cooler to meet you in
person, but uh
>> I do want to say there there's one
exclusive thing that I I haven't really
told anybody. So, just for your show,
I've been in contact with Wits.
>> That's what's up.
>> You might show up to Truth or Gone.
>> Yeah, dude.
>> So, if you guys if you guys have
questions, you should come to Truth or
Con,
>> dude. Yeah, Wits is like I don't know if
he's got a photographic memory or what,
but dude can just he's got a lot of
great information, but yeah, I don't
want to keep you guys too long, but
thank you so much, Jeremiah and Jake. It
was awesome talking. I hope to see
everybody in this chat room at Truther
Con. I know it's in Texas, maybe you
can't make it, but try to, man, you got
over a month to plan for this, and it'd
be so cool to get to meet you guys in
person. It's a chance to get to hang out
with Candid Truth and with all the other
people that you guys probably watch and
subscribe to and looking forward to
seeing you guys there, man. So, we will
talk again another time. Thanks, guys,
for for coming on.
>> Thanks, man.
>> See you guys on our show.
>> Yeah, let me know when, man. I'm on it.
>> All right, guys.
>> See you guys. Thank you guys so much for
joining Candid Truth tonight. I hope you
I hope you guys come to Truth or ConCon
because it is just so cool to come
together as a community of like-minded
people and getting to have Q&A and you
know sometimes you watch a video and
you're like, "Oh, they didn't talk about
this or they didn't talk I wish I could
have asked that guy a question." You
will get to do that at Truther Con.
You'll get to meet and greet with us um
me and my wife and us at Candid Truth.
And we can't do this without you guys.
We love you. We thank you for your
support. If you would like to support
this ministry, you can do so by going to
candidruth.org.
You can do so through Cash App,
Vinmozel, PayPal. We even have uh
Patreon. We also have t-shirts if you
guys like cool t-shirts like the one I'm
wearing right now. Here's a cool can of
truth one. We get about $5 commission on
each of those shirts. We can't do this
without you. We are completely
donor-based. And if you guys have been
giving, we love you. We thank you. And
we cannot thank you enough. And we'll
see you next time on Candid Truth.